hey everybody
welcome in to the live streams this is
market takes
i am dion robon here with you thank you
for being with me on my live on my
youtube live channel and uh you know i
know you could have been anywhere in the
world right now but you're here with me
so i i thank you for that to everyone
who's watching on the the re-recorded
the vod uh who's watching this later i
appreciate you but those of you who are
here with me live thank you very much
y'all are some real ones um look it is
an interesting time in the markets right
now a time of a lot of volatility a time
of a lot of uncertainty i want to get
into that and want to talk about
what's going on in the housing market
and how that is really going to help us
kind of peel back some layers of this
onion that is the economy right now and
tell us what's really happening and tell
us what you know we should be looking
out for
in the future so this week we get a
number of big reports on the housing
market that i think are going to tell us
a whole lot about not just the housing
market but about the economy i'm gonna
break all those down tell you what those
mean and what to look out for this week
um as we check in on the markets it is
another rough day a lot of red
especially in the nasdaq the nasdaq down
more than one percent uh today
it is may 16th monday of course uh mark
it down about more than one percent of
the nasdaq the dow about flat and the s
p 500 down about half a percent uh if
you're looking out into the rest of the
markets right now we've seen it kind of
starting to pull back on those bond
losses as you know the treasury market
has had the worst start to a year on
record we are seeing some buying in the
treasury market the u.s 10-year yield
which is the benchmark that's up a
little bit today in terms of prices down
a little bit on the yields also gold
which had started following his backup
or sorry not gold excuse me oil oil
which had been falling is back up above
110 per barrel uh on the wti side brent
crude they're about the same at about
113 dollars a barrel so
definitely worth watching what's going
on there in the markets gold uh which i
was going to mention is just up a little
bit not a big move in gold but staying
above that 1800 level so all of that to
say that we're seeing a little bit of
fear in the market right now investors
buying those safe haven assets u.s
treasury bonds buying a little bit of
gold stock selling off a little bit
and all that really we're in this
environment of of a good deal of fear
right now we've seen six straight weeks
of selling on the s p 500 six straight
weeks six straight weeks of losses on
the nasdaq seven straight weeks of
losses for the dow jones industrial
average so a consistent selling pattern
a lot of fear the vix which is wall
street's quote unquote fear gauge is
back around 30.
so those are all things that tell us
there's a lot of fear if you were
watching this weekend lloyd blankfein he
is the senior chairman at goldman sachs
saying that he feels a recession is very
very likely uh he said he would be very
prepared for it
if you are running a big company or if
you're just running a household
and you know the the goldman sachs banks
economists cut their expectations for
growth for the us this year um again
another credible serious person coming
out and saying hey i see some risks for
the u.s economy this year i also want to
point out a report that came out this
morning the empire manufacturing report
from the federal reserve bank of new
york
that showed a negative print one of the
most negative prints we've seen in fact
wiping out the gains from the previous
month which was a very good print so we
are starting to see some of those
numbers coming in on economic reports
that are showing a downtrend we saw if
you remember on friday i told y'all to
look out for the consumer sentiment
report from the university of michigan
that came in a new low a new decade long
low lowest in more than 10 years
so all these things like i said pointing
to a a worry about recession from
serious people from serious economists
who know these markets and who watch
them and who take them seriously and i
want to get into housing and talk about
why what we're going to see this week is
going to help get you guys up to up to
speed get you educated on some of the
things that they're seeing in the
markets and some of the trends that
we're seeing so this week we get the
national association of home builders uh
may report that comes out on tuesday
also on tuesday we get building permits
and housing starts going to tell you
what those are and what that means we
also get the big kahuna for this week is
the existing home sales report for april
you'll definitely want to tune in for
that so i'm going to get into what each
of those are why they're important what
they mean
i also want to tell you about the not so
sneak i usually tell you about a sneaky
important release for this week i'm
going to tell you about a not so sneaky
but still important release that you
need to watch for this week that is the
u.s retail sales number those of you
that follow markets know that that is
usually very well watched
so we're going to get into all of that
so look let's get into the national
association of home builders
housing market index that's coming out
on tuesday it's the index for may so
it's early we've only gotten through
about half the month but we're going to
get that preliminary report from the
national association of home builders
on tuesday that's basically going to
tell us what home builders are thinking
as as you've heard if you've been
watching the housing market at all we
have a
distinct and historically low level of
supply meaning there's just not a lot of
houses so home building is is one piece
of that and it's a very large piece of
that the other piece is that folks who
have homes who are in their homes just
don't want to sell but the half that we
can look at and find out some more
information on home builders what's
their sentiment like because if home
builder sentiment is low means they're
probably not going to be building a lot
of houses
now last month we saw sentiment was
still high it was at a 77 which is
pretty well above that 50 level which
separates good from bad just think if
it's above 50 that means sentiment is
generally good if it's below 50 that
means cinnamon is generally bad but
sentiment has been declining
consistently declining we've seen it
sentiment drop
well below 2021 levels and it dropped in
april for the fourth month in a row
we'll see if may turns that around it's
expected to drop economists are
predicting that we're going to see
another drops that be five straight
months of drops in home builder
sentiment homebuilder buyer traffic i'm
sorry buyer traffic that home builders
are seeing is the one piece of that
that's consistently been around that 50
level which again separates good from
bad so watch that buyer traffic number
if you're digging through that report
this week
we also get on that same day on tuesday
housing starts and building permits and
this is one report that comes out you
hear about both how many houses were
actually started how many houses did we
put the shovel in the ground and
actually start building and how many
permits were issued to buy the houses
both of those are are going to be big
numbers that tell us what's actually
happening homebuilder sentiment is great
because it says okay what are these
people thinking what do folks in the
business actually think are they pushing
more business out there are they getting
more work are they hiring more people
are they building more houses but then
we actually see the numbers and that's
housing starts and building permits and
we will get that on tuesday as well
on thursday we get the big kahuna as i'm
calling it that is existing home sales
now existing homes make up about 90 of
houses that are on the market so this
existing home sales is a bigger report
than the new home sales report and those
other reports like housing starts
building permits which just tell us
about new homes right we need those new
homes to create more supply but the sale
of existing homes that tells us what the
market is really looking like what those
machinations in the market are really
doing so existing home sales we get that
report thursday morning that's
definitely going to be something to
watch for
home sales month over month uh last
month fell for the second month in a row
uh down almost three percent from the
prior month and four and a half percent
from a year ago now that's a trend that
we haven't seen much of in this year but
what we have seen is year-over-year
sales is in comparing march to march
2021 comparing april to april 2021.
those have fallen every single month
since august of 2021.
so we're seeing a con
continued decline in sales
in 2022 from the levels that we saw in
2021 that's expected 2021 as i've said
was basically the best year of housing
ever but it's all about the trend the
trend is telling us that we are seeing a
slowdown in buying from people a
consistent slowdown month over month now
whereas we were just getting it year
over year uh prior to march so
definitely something to watch out for
we're also seeing that slower demand
mean that there is greater inventory but
unfortunately the inventory is not being
sold a lot of times because it's just
priced too high because that's the other
piece of this that we're seeing even as
sales slow down prices continue to rise
we saw existing home sales median sales
price the median is at the meeting
the median existing home sales price uh
rise to a record high of 375
000 or over 375 000
that was an increase of more than 15
percent from a year ago that increase is
almost 50 000 so
an average existing home is about 50 000
more expensive was more about fifty
thousand dollars more expensive in march
than it was in march 2021. um if you're
seeing different numbers for those
average home prices you might see some
showing you over four hundred thousand
some showing over 450 000 that's because
different people measure this different
ways this is coming from the national
association of realtors they're putting
that mean or median home median existing
home sales price at 375 000
the census bureau measures it
differently different realtors
associations measure differently but
national association of realtors they've
tracked this for a long time they've got
it at over 375 thousand dollars right
now now the reason i think this report
will be especially important was because
april was the month we saw treasury
yield spike up higher you had a record
year a record month excuse me in april
for treasury yields treasury yields are
directly tied to mortgage rates when
treasury yields go up mortgage rates go
up and it's not the exact same increase
but you can bet that when treasury
yields go up mortgage rates are going to
go up and we saw mortgage rates rise
average mortgage rates on a 30-year
fixed mortgage rise to the highest
they've been in over 10 years during the
month of april so how did buyers respond
did prices continue to rise higher did
sales continue to drop or did we see a
break in that trend because of these
higher than average uh interest rates
and mortgage rates that we were seeing
in april
yields like i said on the 10-year note
which are basically the ones most
correlated to the mortgage market have
started to come down we saw them peak up
over 3.1 percent just about a week ago
they're now down at about 2.9 2.8 5 so a
pretty significant drop in those yields
will that correlate to mortgage rates
and will that make a difference if
you're thinking about buying a home does
the difference between
5.3 and 5.2 mortgage rates make a
difference to you probably not but that
difference between 4.9 and 5.0 that
probably did make a difference so what
did we say from the mortgage market last
month that's going to tell us a lot um
want to get into before we get out of
here and i want to thank you all for
being with us again on this live stream
with me dionne bowen a reporter for the
wall street journal talking about what's
going on in the housing market also how
all those things relate to the economy
and a big report we've got coming out
this week is retail sales that's
expected to decline in april from march
and that's really important because we
are seeing inflation continue to rise
higher now when inflation rise higher
that means things cost more that means
retail sales should be higher because
they're not counting the number of
things that were sold they're counting
the amount of dollar volume that was
handled so if the amount of dollar
volume that was handled declined while
prices went up that means people are
really pulling back from purchasing and
really slowing down what they're doing
so that's something definitely to watch
also a really important note about the
last report we saw from march retail
sales you saw an increase in overall
retail sales but almost all of that in
fact more than all of that came from
increased price of gasoline uh core
retail sales if you exclude gasoline
actually declined and online sales which
had been picking up consistently for a
long time declined by 6.4
that's something to watch out for um
if you excluded just gas retail sales
actually fell by 0.3
while overall prices rose by 1.2
what does that mean that means there's a
one and a half percent difference
between what prices did and what sales
did that's not good so if you run
recession watch again just something to
keep track of and say uh oh there are
some numbers moving in the wrong
direction we will see if numbers
continue to move in that wrong direction
or if they picked back up in april from
where they were in march definitely
something to keep an eye on uh so again
thank you all for tuning in and being
with me on this live stream um we talked
through the national association of home
builders home uh home index and what
that's gonna be doing what that's
telling us about the economy what home
builders think we talked about housing
starts and building permits which is
going to tell us how many new projects
got started we also talked about that
existing home sales report that's going
to be coming out from the national
association of realtors those are
tuesdays uh for the home starts housing
starts and building permits as well as
the nahb index and thursday for that
existing home sales report and watch out
for that retail sales report this week
the not so sneaky report that i think
you need to cheat to look out for anyway
i'm deon robon thank you guys for being
with me here as we walk through this on
the live stream housing very important
make sure you're looking out for those
reports this week and be with me next
week we do this every monday right here
on youtube i will do it again next
monday i hope to see you there